a guy you knew was going to be executed
the real Buffalo Bill Gary heidnick
abducted six black women and put them in
a pit under his house and electrocuted
one of them and fed them to the others
whenever the power went out on his unit
this sick would start doing the
performance of these women in Terror oh
my God he I bet he gonna kill us dudes
would be beaten on their doors trying to
drown him out the guards come in and
spray you with pepper spray they want
you to hear his [__] what was your
feeling the day he went they put chains
on this man and marched them right past
my door and he went like this at me I
was like [__] God God is [__] ass back
years before he had abducted a mentally
ill black woman and impregnated her
after keeping her hostage that child
from the rib came out of nowhere and she
wanted to forgive her daddy and when he
saw her he broke he ate all that on the
spot when he saw his beautiful biracial
daughter
the true Geordie podcast